thank you uh good morning everybody to
this latest meeting of the covered 19
public engagement board of traffic
council
um
can i thank you all for your attendances
today i have apologies from councillors
denise weston rob chilton and i've got
an apology from ellie caddick as well
are there any further apologies
i don't see any thank you very much
are there any decorations of interest by
anybody in today's agenda items
i don't see any there thank you very
much let me just clear that's off my
screen
um and so the minutes of the last
meeting i wasn't present at the last
meeting i have read through the minutes
but can i take those uh minutes as a
true and accurate record please from
those that were present
yeah
thank you very much indeed uh council
lloyd
um so we'll move on to the next item
which is the update on
kovid19 situation in trafford by eleanor
this is elena's last meeting with us
before she hands over the the the
important to helen so off you go thank
you
thanks very much and yes i'm off on a
sabbatical for six months so i'll be
back in april but um the current
situation but i'm very very pleased that
helen golins the deputy director will be
will be taking over um as director for
the next six months and you're in
extremely capable hands
um so the situation we've got in
trafford at the moment is that our rates
are still stubbornly high they have come
down a bit but they're around about the
300 320 per 100 000 mark
which is much higher than we'd like
obviously we've seen that increase going
up with um increase in testing with
schools returning and we are seeing a
lot of cases and a rising cases in our
um under 14 age groups some of those in
both in primary and secondary schools
typically the top end of primary and
into secondary schools we are seeing a
lot of cases
um
[Music]
we are encouraged we would encourage
people therefore to continue to be
cautious around covert the vaccination
program is working well
but we're seeing a slowing in the uptake
of vaccination and as you know there's
always been an inequality an uptake on a
vaccination with people living in more
deprived areas being less likely to be
vaccinated and that increases the risk
obviously to the po to our general
population
and and to people because um if you are
unvaccinated it is
your and other people around you are
also unvaccinated it's more likely that
people the disease will spread and
there's more likely to be serious
illness so we really would urge people
to take up that vaccination it's not too
late to be vaccinated
the a few things again on vaccination
the 12 to 15 program is starting i think
it starts today in our local in one of
our schools locally um this program is
all being done with parental consent no
child will be vaccinated in the school
at um at present unless parents have
actively consented and if and we were
asked what would happen if a child
didn't want to be vaccinated even if
their parents wanted to be and they
won't be vaccinated at this point if the
child didn't want to be vaccinated again
that conversation would be held with the
parents so nobody needs to be worried
that their child will be vaccinated
against their will
it is all done with consent having said
that the vaccine is safe and i would
thoroughly recommend it to everybody who
is called for vaccination so i do think
it's worth doing
but
it's not it's not being forced on any
child
um the booster vaccination program has
been announced and will be starting and
people who are in the
priority groups one to nine so that's
the over people over 50 people living in
care homes health and social care
frontline workers people with
clinically vulnerable and carers will
all be being invited to be vaccinated
it'll be at least a six-month gap
between when you were last vaccinated
and people will be being called either
through their workplace or by their gp
so you don't need to be contacting your
gp at this point and you shouldn't
expect to be called until at least six
months after your vaccination
so
as a corollary to that i would say if
everybody over 50 should now be getting
their invitations for their flu vaccine
and please do take that up as soon as
you're offered it don't wait to hear
about your covert vaccine it may well be
that they will they may be done at the
same time but it may be too parallel
processes so don't delay having the flu
vaccine because we are quite worried
about flu levels for this winter
in terms of the general messaging i
would thoroughly recommend that
everybody continues to to take covid
seriously because the rates are high
across the whole of our borough um if
you have been vaccinated hopefully you
will be you know the vaccination will
will work well for you and um we we you
won't be hospitalized but we are
starting to see some outbreaks in our
care homes which has been a change we've
had you know the whole summer we've done
so well with our care homes so it is
really important that if you are
visiting someone in a care home please
do take a lateral flow test before you
visit please do
use the face coverings please do be
cautious um in in any setting
particularly where there are older or
more vulnerable people and i will
continue to say you know in in crowded
spaces in places like supermarkets just
give everybody space so everybody can
feel safe in the spaces that we all need
to be going to give people space wear
your face covering um kovid remains a
very nasty disease and um
we can prevent it if we're careful
take that vaccination keep keep your two
meters away from people
if you're worried people you know meet
your friends outside limit the number of
people you see make sure you stay in
well-ventilated areas and and respect
the needs and anxieties of others but
the the other thing is you know really
do try and make sure you get out you see
your friends you get some exercise
because that's all really really
important as well
i think that's all i wanted to say
thank you elena are there any questions
at all from anyone for eleanor at all
yes council blackburn
hey thank you can i ask um is there a
method for contacting the parents of
homeschool children with regard to
vaccination
there will be um and i don't know if
helen has the answer to it but if not we
can find out but there will be a method
of doing it because we we vaccinate we
always have a program
all the vaccinations are offered to all
children in traffic including homeschool
children helen are you
[Laughter]
yeah sorry i've lost the ability to
raise my hand on i just i may have
accidentally applauded i meant to
actually raise my hand i do apologize
but yeah so
kate murdock is leading the vaccination
program from mft side uh and she um
will be working closely with the
inclusion team
in terms of ensuring that all young
people are invited by the october half
term but we are due to have a discussion
to make sure that that all families
receive the
an invite and an accessible vaccination
if they choose to um vaccinate their
children as well
okay
could i also ask is there any data for
different age bands for those people
who've been double jabbed
yes we've got lots of data on all of
this um and it's i think some of it's in
the briefing that's sent round and if
not um we can we can send that round but
if we have got um we have got data by
age band on vaccination
yeah and thirdly um at health scrutiny
last week
um dr mark jarvis was
he said that the lateral flow tests
weren't worth taking because half the
time
they weren't accurate
so
um i would
take issue with dr jarvis on that um so
i would say a lateral flow test taken as
a one-off is probably not of a
particularly helpful
um
tool because particularly when they're
self-administered and after people
people who've been um supervised when
they're taking the lateral flow test
it's more likely to be accurate than
people who are doing it in their own
home and we know the accuracy drops over
time because i think people get a bit
more casual with doing it
so the lateral flow tests um have a
pretty good at finding people who are
positive
um who are
they're not very likely to give you a
false positive
but they are quite likely to give you a
false negative so they probably pick up
between
two
about two-thirds of the positive cases
so they possib they probably miss
between a third and a quarter of the
positive cases
so that's why we particularly encourage
people if they have any symptoms to go
for a pcr test because the pcr test is
much more accurate and what we don't
want is somebody doing a lateral flow
test who's got symptoms doing a lateral
flow test being falsely reassured by the
result of that lateral flow test
particularly if they're only doing it
say you know on a very ad hoc basis so
what we're encouraging people to do with
the lateral flow test is do them
routinely do them twice a week and
remember how to do them well
so really you know make sure that you do
get that swab properly up your nose and
down your throat which is not a pleasant
experience
so we would encourage people to do them
out twice a week
um if if you're going into a high risk
setting if you're going to visit you
know if you're going to visit people um
in a care home or anything like that or
if you're working in a in a high-risk
setting we really would encourage people
to do those lateral flow tests regularly
because they're more likely to be picked
up then what you're more likely to pick
up that infection that way rather than
if you're just doing it as one of we
also really strongly encourage people to
if you've got symptoms of covid to go
straight for the pcr test because we
don't want anyone to be falsely
reassured and i think that's probably
what dr jarvis will have been
thinking about is that there is a risk
of that false reassurance and obviously
false reassurance is much more dangerous
um than than not knowing because if you
if you've got symptoms you do a test it
comes back negative and it's a false
negative you could well think well now
i'm going to go and do all the things
that i wouldn't have done
otherwise or am i you know i feel so
much better now that i've done that i'm
going to go and do x y and z and that
that obviously does it hugely increase
the risk to people
so
it is a lateral flow test is
it's a useful tool
but it isn't the whole answer
okay thanks very much thank you
thank you council blackburn councillor
yeah
thanks jeff um yeah it was just about
the care homes uh
it is concerning that um you know the
the numbers are going up in the care
homes and
um
is there anything that we can sort of do
in relation to that other than what
we're doing at this moment in time
so what we're doing is we're continuing
obviously i mean the care homes and the
care home managers have been you know
absolutely superb throughout this they
have taken this so seriously and and you
know the number of calls i've been on
you know when we've had outbreaks in
care homes and it sometimes it's been
absolutely heartbreaking you know the
the situation and and the you know the
the concern and care that our care home
managers and staff show for their
residents the love that they show for
them is phenomenal um so i would uh so
what we have been doing is just making
sure that all of our care homes are
having reminders about general infection
prevention control measures
i think as people have become more
casual about using face coverings and so
on in the general in your general life
again that can drift into the workplace
and people perhaps where people were
making sure that they were managing the
social distancing more um perhaps in
breaks and so on um that may you know we
are reminding people to really try and
make sure that they don't they don't um
they come into contact with each other
any more than they need to and so we're
doing a lot of reminders around with
people we're doing reviews but i would
say in most cases the care homes when
we've been looking through what's
happening in the outbreaks
it does seem to be being brought in from
out outside because as rates go up in
the general population as they are they
remain high you know people will be will
be regularly exposed um
almost all of our care home staff now
obviously are double vaccinated almost
all of our catherine residents are
double vaccinated care homes will be one
of the first places that get the
boosters
in and i know rebecca will be talking
about that in a moment they will be
having a plan to make sure that all of
our care home residents do get that
booster job as quickly as possible
so i think those are the things those
are the main things we're doing but i
think the general advice is and the
general my general message to all of us
is
while rates in the population stay high
all of our more vulnerable people are
necessarily at increased risk so we all
have to do everything we can to keep
ourselves and our and our more
vulnerable friends family neighbors as
safe as we possibly can and that's
through wearing our face coverings in
crowded places keeping that social
distancing and being if you like over
the wear at all times
can i just uh
ask about
some staff in care homes who
have been jabbed
more importantly
that haven't
are we losing stuff now because of that
at the moment um the staff asks i mean
again rebecca will have more of the
details and i don't know if there's
anyone else from social care but there's
a big program of work to check with the
care homes where any issues are going to
be and um and how to mitigate any risk
from that so that piece of work is going
on at the moment we have got um there
are obviously some care home staff who
don't want to be vaccinated
and um and there are concerns about the
impact that that will have on our homes
but there are a lot of plans in place at
the moment to try and make sure that
that risk is is absolutely minimized and
again our current manager is an adult
social care staff have been phenomenal
in in addressing this issue and trying
to make it as safe as possible
the target date i think is
is it november or something like that
yes so it's the 11th of november
i do think that we need to kind of
monitor that situation because um
obviously we don't want a shortage of
staff
absolutely that that is being monitored
on i think almost daily basis there is a
list of all the staff whether they're
vaccinated and what the issues are for
any care home and how those risks will
be managed that is um diane eaton karen
ahmed and their teams are absolutely on
this
as you would expect
thank you councillor any further
questions at all
yes council lloyd
um i
i agree about um support keeping your
distance from other people and wearing
masks but actually you find that you're
in the minority a lot of people have
abandoned masks
um even in supermarkets some of the um
restrictions that they have before you
know like spacing doesn't happen so
people
use curing normally
um and i just think it's a shame that
people don't realize how bad covet can
be
and how deadly it can be and and i just
know how you manage
cross
uh
restrictions to cope it down
i know it's it's a very difficult
message isn't it and i was in scotland
recently and in scotland everybody is
still wearing masks in indoor spaces and
so on and it and it is markedly
different here um i think all we can do
is continue to make the continue to ask
people to show that respect i think in
the main as well i mean i've certainly
um
i think i've got very used to have
especially in supermarket queues i've
got very used to having that space
around you and it's a very nice feeling
isn't it
not you know having having a bit more
space and i i did actually um come over
very old middle-aged woman and told
somebody off who was coming too close to
me the other day um and he did step back
and um
[Music]
actually you know what it's things like
i mean it's a ridiculous thing because
it's such a safe safe place um but you
sort of think you don't want people
coming in and you know you're worried
then that they might put their hand in
your handbag more than anything else
don't you
so you do get used to that space so i
think we should just um you know
politely ask people to step back um if
if we do feel um that they're getting
too close and most people are very very
responsive to that
um so i think i think we have to you
know treat people with respect be polite
but i i personally think it is important
that we continue to wear our face
coverings and and to keep give people
distance and show everybody that respect
and courtesy and that's that's what i
strongly encourage everyone everyone to
do
thank you and i kind of just couldn't
agree more i've just come back last week
from two weeks in france
um and everywhere you go indoors uh
supermarkets
anything
more than twenty thousand you wear a
mask you also have to produce for every
single bar and restaurant you go into
your covered status of double jabbed and
everyone accepts it you're scanned in
uh you walk around the restaurant you
put your mask on um and and it's
actually it's absolutely upset and we've
missed a trick here and you know it's
not lost on me the highest infection
rate in europe is the uk
and it remains to be the uk and it will
remain as long as you know
people
don't upset well but as long as people
think it's over and it isn't
i think that's sadly the case i think we
do need to you know and our
hospitalization rates are you know that
they are steady um and you know
everybody who's hospitalized with covert
is is in a sense somebody who perhaps
now we that could you know it's becoming
a much more preventable disease but we
all need to we all need to engage in
that prevention
thank you are there any further
questions at all
thank you ellen and thank you for your
contribution to these meetings over the
past how long now for every almost next
thing that we're gonna go on and on
to helen taking over the mantle in two
weeks time
um the next the next item on the agenda
is the self-isolation pathfinder update
from cursive i don't see her on the call
and i did read from the last set of
minutes that the the pilot has now
ended is that correct
uh yeah councillor freeman so kirsty
kirsty has been successful and she is
our new outbreak manager uh our outbreak
um
management and contact tracing hub
manager so she started in her role
last week i think it's been a bit of a
baptism of fire but um she's just sent a
note to say that the self-isolation
pathfinder has ended now and that she'll
be bringing an evaluation report to the
next pebb
thank you very much indeed for that
helen so we can move on then to mass
testing and ben good morning ben
good morning thank you very much
um so a few updates today on testing
starting off with schools
so second schools have completed now
their on-site testing of pupils with
heavy people tested twice
some schools in trafford were struggling
a little bit for capacity to carry out
the testing so because of that um our
own testing team supported five of them
with that process
in total the team carried out 4 301
tests and we found a number of positives
which otherwise would have been missed
if we hadn't been able to support those
schools and i guess i raised up um in
terms of counsellor blackburn's point
before around the effectiveness of
watchful flow tests and as eleanor says
it's very much about how we use them and
i think when we use lateral flow tests
to do case finding for asymptomatic
cases when we assume that there are
likely to be cases because obviously in
this instance it was you know people's
going back after spending all summer
together you know we we need to expect
cases there and we do the exact same
approach when it comes to um if there's
an outbreak in key settings um so i
think there is a really big advantage in
terms of using larger flow tests in that
manner um and the other bit obviously is
around making sure that we still
continue to push people testing on a
track week we sleep
part of me twice weekly basis
um so another element is around our
universities and colleges so both ua 92
and traffic college have been
encouraging students to test upon their
return uh travel college completed
completed on-site testing and we
provided ua92 with additional test kits
to support that process so essentially
the first thing that happened when
students returned um was they were
thrusted a lot to flow test kit in their
face but again that has been positive
they have found a couple of positives by
that route so it has been a very
worthwhile exercise doing that
um another change recently is around
international travel
so fully vaccinated passengers will um
soon take electro flow tests on day two
rather than a pcr test on day two and
day eight and the pre-departure tests
are no longer needed so this change
comes in from the 4th of october um
anyone who tests positive will then go
and get a pcr test which would be
sequenced whether to find new variants
um testing for vaccinated passages does
not change um so the same kind of day
two and day eight pcr tests and
obviously anyone coming from a redless
country again exactly the same um so
that hotel quarantine package as part of
that i guess in terms of the change for
fully vaccinated passengers as much as
you are um asked to take that paid for a
larger flow test on day two we're
obviously very much encouraging those um
to go get hold of those free electric
flow tests and continue testing on that
twice weekly basis and because we know
it's really really useful as a way to go
and find those positives um
just to reiterate as i said before a a
one-off flat flow test is is not great
at giving permission to go and see
family friends etc but being able to do
so on a regular basis um is is a really
good way of identifying positives that
otherwise would have been missed so we
do really want to kind of emphasize that
kind of mixture of case finding and that
regular testing in order to use lots of
flow tests in the best possible way
and that's all for me
thank you any questions at all for ben
i don't see any ben i don't see me in
the chat either so thank thank you very
much
uh very just sorry can't
freeman sorry i was just going i was
just going to reiterate actually on that
point that ben made that i should have
been making earlier that lateral flow
test can be incredibly helpful for that
case finding when we know there's a high
prevalence so we use them a lot in
outbreaks in businesses or in schools or
in any setting because they're a really
useful way of doing a quick check on
everybody in that place where you know
that there's like raised likelihood um
so they they are they do have a very
strong place in that case finding as
well
thank you
um moving on then uh to contact tracing
outbreak manager with helen do it take
it helen that kirsty will from next week
from the next meeting will be taking
this this part from you
thank you yeah so she's cursed he'll be
regularly attending so thanks chair so
the outbreak management and contact
tracing hub has been busy since um
the beginning of september but we now
have a full contact tracing team in
place and so there they are
offering real kind of resilience to our
service being able to
um follow up cases that we receive from
the national team so on average we
receive 30 cases per day people who
haven't been contacted by the national
team and our team follow them up
obviously these are people who it is
more difficult to contact either they
choose not to engage or there may be
issues with um
language or or other kind of complex
issues but our team managed to contact
on average 35 of those cases per day and
of them 10 end up as being welfare calls
so there they then plug them into other
elements of support so it's doing a
really important role in our community
we also have laura strong who is working
in our team and she works predominantly
with our businesses
um so she when we when we're aware of
what is known as either a common
exposure or coincidence
she will contact the businesses directly
kind of go through
what's happening what are the cases and
what measures they've got in place so we
are working with 10 different workplaces
across trafford at the moment where they
have increased covered activity
but obviously another other area again
is our care home so we work incredibly
closely as a team with
anna nobley and the ipc team um to
support all the outbreaks that are
currently going on in our care homes and
i think it's the vaccination message is
so important what we are seeing is um
increased activity over the last two
weeks um and there has been uh
some people have ended up hospitalized
but i think the important messages they
are not as poorly as they would have
been if they weren't vaccinated but
obviously we have to recognize that any
hospitalization for an older person um
you know can have negative outcomes so
it's just really pushing that message
that eleanor spoke about in terms of
vaccination
our schools which i'm sure you're all
very interested in have kept us busy so
since the beginning of term we have we
have had um over 360 cases across our
schools that include staff and pupils
76 inquiries so that's where our team
has helped schools to work through
scenarios or issues that they may have
received from the staff at a school
we've done five eye assessments so this
is a new framework that we use alongside
the new guidance to ensure that
schools have done everything they
possibly can do in terms of minimizing
the risk and our schools are brilliant
the capacity and the understanding of
risk in terms of covid is really high
across all our schools we've had four
outbreak control teams for schools
across trafford
um
at the moment we do have um one school
one high school that's in outbreak
measures under primary school that is in
outbreak measures but the school again
are managing incredibly well it's
brilliant they're doing a great job
just to link us in with ben is that we
do have an mtu so mobile testing unit
at one of our primary schools on friday
um
due to increased activity there
so it has been busy but it feels
manageable at the moment so thank you
thank you very much for that helen any
questions for helen at all
no i don't see any at all thank you very
much for that input helen we therefore
move on to mass vaccination welcome
rebecca domain from the ccg rebecca
good good morning chair and thank you
everybody um
to be honest i think ellen has covered
quite a lot of what i was going to say
so thank you eleanor and you've saved me
a bit of a job there but i will pick up
on some questions asked so
and just in terms of numbers um as
things stand in trafford total first and
second
vaccinations
doses total just over 328 000 that's 170
um first doses 158 second doses i know
counselors comments about the um
breakdowns of first and second doses
across the age groups and again happy to
see like that and i know previously
we've been asked about particularly to
um
30 year old breakdown so at present
we've got about 70 percent of the 18 to
30 year old groups who have um received
a first dose um
and about physics who have received
zelda says that that's where i was
seeing a little bit of a slow down uh
we've had
a look at the data so we've got uh there
is more
hesitancy and that seems to be in the
older end of that young adult age group
so we're doing some further including
some and conversations with the trafford
center about some additional pop-ups and
16 year olds um
rebecca you appear to have friends
and they are um we're just waiting for
the latest patreon 16 to 17 year olds
college at both the student ultimate
site can people hear me now
yeah can people hear me yes yep
so
no you think again
rebecca do you want to try and turn your
camera off and see if that improves
we appear to have
lost rebecca at the moment she's frozen
um
i mean just we're um we're looking at
pop-up sites for some of the 16 and 17
year olds for particularly looking at
sites like traffic college we've been
working with ua 92 to make sure all the
students going back have been vaccinated
um
so
and obviously schools program has has is
now about to start i don't know
um
we're keeping a very close eye on these
inequalities in in uptake and trying to
make sure that we're designing materials
that will appeal to different age groups
as we do more analysis on who the types
of people that are currently
unvaccinated so a lot of work is going
on to try and make sure that we get up
to 90 percent across every single ward
and every every um
lower level area and across different
groups within trafford thanks helen are
you back with us rebecca now can you
hear us
yes can you hear me yes we can yeah okay
sorry about that um so i don't know what
ellen has just picked up there but um
yes so 16 to 17 year olds we mentioned
we're doing some work with colleges and
six forms so that's where um we're up to
in terms of numbers
um
the 12 to 15 um healthy school age
program as other mentioned is being
delivered through our school age
immunisation service um with two test
sites and being run today so wellington
school in timperley in trafford and is
being um offer the pupils there are
being offered the vaccine today and
that's as i say to look at the process
around consent information screening
data collection
cold chain and and and how things are
operating in the school so we'll get
some feedback from that and we are
expecting the full plan from colleagues
at mft who are running this program and
to be presented at the manchester and
trafford cell later today so by then
we'll have an idea of um the trajectory
in terms of how many pupils um
will have the ability to be offered in
the vaccine before half term although
we're conscious of the administration
of the actual vaccine may run beyond
that time and
so again we'll give a further update and
there was a question about homeschooling
or pupils who may not be in school on
the day so just to confirm that there is
not there will be a second specification
issued after half term which will
essentially be kind of a mop up service
i don't like the terminology mop up but
that will ensure that any um pupils who
may have been missed who still want the
opportunity there will be a rerun of the
program so that's happening and the
booster program as i mentioned is going
live and and the booking service opened
yesterday so those um individuals who
are eligible um longer than six months
since their second dose will now start
to be invited as elena mentioned through
their gp directly or through the
national booking service and we are
going to obviously start to present um
data going forward on the uptake of the
booster program so we'll have data
presented on first second and booster
going forward
um in terms of the booster um we have
had confirmation from mft that the
hospital hub vaccination sites will be
reopened at trafford general with insure
and mri for um health and social care
workers and i'm just awaiting dates and
details but as per the process last time
we will be able to share information and
staffing lists from um across the health
and social care system in trafford so
the hospital hubs will be available for
staff to have their vaccine as well as
local vaccination services
and in terms of the booster i think i've
mentioned before all five of our
networks are offering the um the booster
program and we've got three additional
pharmacies on board as well
in addition to the three that we had for
phases one and two so we've got really
significant coverage now across trafford
and again thanks to all those local
vaccination services
in terms of the care homes again i heard
the question asked so each of our
networks who are aligned to a care home
are now scheduling in visits to the
homes again based on the schedule of the
first and second doses so they will be
arranging visits into the homes to pick
up both residents and staff and and
again that the the um details of staff
and residents um who are receiving their
vaccine will be included on the daily
sit back that we get from the council so
again we'll be able to see um up taking
numbers and then staff will also be um
given the details of any walk-in clinics
and again the hospital hub so that we've
got plenty of access points for um care
staff as well as health staff and in
terms of the um mandated vaccine for
care home staff um colleagues were quite
right the the um deadline is the first
of november for both um doses
so the deadline for the first dose has
now passed that was the 16th of
september trafford is performing well
across gm in terms of the numbers of
staff who have been vaccinated but there
are a number of staff who still haven't
that's not taking away the efforts we
are still doing some proactive work to
persuade and encourage and even if
they've missed the dose of the first
deadline we'll be able to have some
pragmatic conversations about
potentially suspending work but allowing
staff to then continue and if they
choose to take the vaccine now so that
was it from me and apologies for my
internet issues that's fine thank you
rebecca any questions at all rebecca yes
councillor new grosh
thank you chair um so my question's
about the healthy 12 to 15 year old
group can i get a little bit more
information on that specifically on
consent um as honestly this age group to
me is
the least clear uh it was the one that
was perhaps
the most difficult to decide um so could
i get some more information how that
trial's running or what exactly is
involved and
and where consent is being granted on
you know how it's been granted thank you
um yep so the the consent process is
being managed and coordinated again
through the school-aged immunisation
service so the consent form and the
documentation has all been um nationally
produced and that's part of the
commissioning pack that's gone to each
of the providers so it will be up to
that team to um gain the consent of the
um the child and the parent we can share
copies of the forms and as i say at the
moment i've not got the numbers um from
that service in terms of um how many of
the children and parents offered are
actually consenting to the vaccine so
that data will be available next time
but the the documentation is all
nationally produced and issued through
that school age immunisation service
what's that fire for your counsellor
thank you
yeah i think alan did make it clear at
the very start i think you might have
joined a bit late to council new
that we would we would only be um
vaccinating 12 to 15 hours with parental
consent is that correct eleanor
yes that's right so the um they have to
give written consent so um schools will
vary whether they do it by an email or
whether they have a form that the child
that the parent signs and brings in but
no child will be vaccinated um in this
round with the program without parental
consent
um
the there will not be they won't be
doing the gaelic consenting in in this
at this point
thank you for confirming that um any
further questions at all
yes eve please hi there uh so less of a
question but just more of an add-on to
what rebecca was outlining just so
people are aware as well there is
a national what appears to be a national
delay with the release of the coveted
vaccines for the booster programme so
i'm obviously in contact with them the
pcns and the practices delivering it
and um they're they're waiting to get
notification of when they will receive
their vaccines so they're ready to go
mobilized staffed ready to do the
booster program but um the
they're just missing the vaccine at the
moment and actually just so you're aware
slightly off um subject but it's the
same for flu so one of the main
distributors of the flu vaccine
have said there's a two to three week
delay
um
and that's the one that tends to provide
the vaccine to
practices you might notice some
community pharmacies are already doing
it so there's um
a but there's a delay for general
practice and that's not just for traffic
that's uh nationwide
thank you eve thank you for that
no further questions
no so we'll move on then to uh community
engagement and welcome nigel nigel smith
thank you
thank you chair so uh first thing i
wanted to mention today was to say that
the team have produced an update report
which highlights some of the key
activities and achievements over the
last three to four months
um it covers our shape up for safe
summer program during august
highlighting some of the key outcomes
from that work and there's also a link
to a short video
uh our school engagement work including
our support for the testing teams at
schools and the school poster
competition that we ran
um it covers the different kind of door
knocking activity that we've undertaken
to gain community insight and share
guidance and messaging there's also a
case study on there on where where we
made a difference and there's also an
update on the volunteering strategy and
our volunteer coordination work so
that report just needs final sign off
and then we will be looking to send that
round to all elected members
and i'm also happy to send that on to
other ped members if they would be
interested in seeing that
i also wanted to mention that we did a
kind of small
restructure of the team at the moment
which is coming up through where we now
have two engagement coordinator
posts who can lead on and coordinate
engagement projects and programs of work
so this should mean as a team that we're
able to deliver more programs similar to
the successful summer program that we
ran and so we appointed those two
coordinator posts yesterday and uh we'll
now be working with them on putting our
plans together and
shaping our
engagement activity through autumn and
winter
um
one bit of work that i wanted to
highlight was that we are supporting the
public health team on a piece of
engagement work to better understand the
reasons and barriers to
vaccination in those areas particularly
where we've seen a lower vaccine uptake
and that should help us to better
understand um you know how we can better
provide vaccination services and more
more effectively
so we previously piloted that uh an
evidence-based questionnaire which was
developed by the public health team we
previously private piloted that in the
clifford ward
in august and then last week we did some
work
on thursday and friday in partington
where we did some door knocking
visits um where there was on the back of
some work that your housing group were
already doing in that area
and that was with the revised version of
the questionnaire so what we are doing
now is work there's a working group
being set up by the public health team
and we're now looking at the most kind
of effective way to roll out that
questionnaire
further over the next few weeks
um
in terms of vaccinations we're obviously
continuing to promote and signpost
people particularly to the walking
clinics um continuing to support clinics
where they need assistance either from
the team or from our pool of trained and
experienced volunteers
and we'll be supporting the pop-up
clinics which rebecca mentioned at the
colleges or trafford center
where the you know the teams which the
vaccine operations team will be
delivering over the coming weeks and
where they need engagement support and
also the work of
volunteers
i can also give you a short update in
relation to the comms team as well
um and they are currently pushing their
vaccine messages particularly to the 16
17 year olds and the 1830s
um and they are refreshing their digital
ad campaign with three kind of things
they're looking at so firstly
a seasonal theme so moving from the
previous summer focus that they had but
moving on to more of an autumn winter
focus for example around halloween and
christmas
a theme around it's not too late so
making people aware that despite the
booster program coming through
that they can still have their first
dose now
and also highlights needs a sort of that
theme of protecting your family and
highlighting the high percentage of
people that are already vaccinated
and the other thing to mention
uh finally is that there will be some
outdoor advertising through uh advance
that will be
entrapped over the next couple of weeks
so uh two promotes a
vaccine uptake so they're gonna be on
the 25th and 26th of september in the
clifford ward
and on the 30th september 1st october in
partington
so that's the update from each chair
thank you thank you nigel any questions
at all for nigel
i don't see it at all so thank you for
that um
which means it's on to any of the
business it's only the business of
today's meeting
none well in that case can i thank you
all for your attendances this morning
and the date the next meeting will be 10
o'clock on the 6th of october and i'll
end by again thanking elena for her
inputs for the past however long it's
basic 9 10 months 12 well seems forever
actually enough
but but thank you very much and all the
very very best with the the research
you're going to do
thank you very much and thank you very
much i'd like to thank the this this
committee as well for all the support
you've given because it's been it's been
a fabulous resource for us so thank you
very much to everyone on on this group
thank you
thank you bye-bye everybody see you soon
cheers
bye